il a fait compter un an et en pleine
santé et pourtant il y a quinze jours
ils subissaient une double intervention
sont les corner incroyable quarante huit
heures après l'opération il quittait
l'hôpital une convalescence pour le
moins raccourcis grâce à une première
chirurgicale
il a été opéré en belgique à l'aide d'un
robot à commande vocale avec cette
nouvelle technique les médecins n'ont
pas eu besoin d'ouvrir le thorax
anne mourgues dominique maes reportage
ce matin guy dave a parcouru 20 km à
vélo et pourtant il y à 14 jours
exactement il était à l'hôpital
opéré pour une double intervention sur
les artères coronaires
habituellement la convalescence prend
plus de deux mois sans - effet château
un mot je me sens très bien
vous sentez encore prêt à partir et vous
allez bientôt retourner au travail
une convalescence réduite pas de
cicatrice qui grâce à zeus ce drôle de
petit robot c'était le 4 septembre
l'opération de guy a été entièrement
filmée
d'habitude le chirurgien ouvre le thorax
la juste trois petits trous 2 pour les
bras du robot et les instruments le
dernier pour la caméra
celle ci est commandée par la fois le
chirurgien manipule le robot il voit
l'opération sur son écran il reconnaît
ces gestes sont beaucoup plus précis les
mains d'un chirurgien vont trembler un
petit peu alors les bras mécanique du
rebond ne tremble absolument pas et ne
donne une précision vraiment un millier
de près
la technique est toute récente les
premiers tests remonte à février c'était
à strasbourg sur le coeur d'un animal
mais le robot pourrait bien s'imposer
dans les salles d'opération
dans une intervention chirurgicale pour
dix minutes soit un quart d'heure
pendant une période particulièrement
difficile
on a souvent et les gens souvent besoin
d'une aide et cette aide elles existent
déjà par les moyens de visioconférence
est ce qu'on appelle le télé mentoring
c'est avec le chirurgien
fait appel un autre chirurgien plus
experts qui lui donne des conseils et
bien outre ses conseils le chirurgien
vont pouvoir prendre les manettes et
opéré à distance pendant 10 minutes ou
pendant un quart d'heure une opération
assistée par ordinateur certains voient
même plus loin
imagine grâce au robot le patient un
endroit et le chirurgien pourquoi pas à
l'autre bout du monde